aïe aïe aïe alors la dernière fois
j'étais à côté d'une jeune femme
charmante j'avais tiré un truc c'était
embrasser votre voisine donc devoir vous
devez dire du mal de votre films ou
livres ou disque tombe ou kg d'ailleurs
- oui je veux dire du mal c'est vraiment
moi qui les crises et les rares chez les
hommes politiques mais à l'annoncé
vous avez des olives marie caroline est
alors les raisons du mal pour voir
mais non je ramenais avant de dire du
mal moi j'ai eu la chance de vivre avec
un homme qui m'a tout appris justement
qui m'a appris ça gémit donc
je vais
c'est joli est ce que l'amour rend
aveugle en philosophie parfois oui ça
les rues c'est un génie tous les jours
on est bien tous les deux elle est pas
mal non mais je suis toujours amoureux -
rennes a fait la joie qui est pas mal
non plus tu sais au bas c'est gentil à 3
mai bombe ou un philosophe